[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
May 19th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
as the cost of living Rises and people
live longer lives many retirees are
passing up Florida to spend their later
years and many have chosen to live in
neighboring Alabama Wall Street Journal
contributor Cecile rodder joins us to
discuss why Alabama and what other
states and cities can learn from the
shifting trend
so Cecile traditionally Florida often
comes up as a retirement destination
option for people and for a lot of
retirees it makes Financial sense
Florida is one of a handful of states
with no income tax so why are retirees
being priced out this story actually was
born from another story I was writing
about Fort Lauderdale which of course is
a traditional retirement community and I
was interviewing a professor at Florida
Atlantic University was talking about
how much that region was changing how
much home values were going up because
so many Tech workers and Financial
Services Workers were moving there and
almost as a throwaway line he said well
the only collateral damage is that there
were Tyrese and snowbirds that
traditionally would come and move to
Fort Lauderdale or spend months of the
year here can no longer afford to be
here because house prices are so high
and so I said well where are they going
and he said a lot of them are moving to
Alabama as it happens home prices with
the changing Florida economy and people
from every everywhere moving there to
work especially to these traditional
retirement destinations on sort of the
western coast of Florida and in
Southeastern Florida home prices have
exploded and really are no longer
affordable for a lot of Americans now
you spoke to several people who've
looked outside the Sunshine State and
have settled in Baldwin County Alabama
where is that in Alabama so Baldwin
counties and the southwestern part of
Alabama and if you imagine it like an
oval on the on the right side on the
Eastern side you have the Florida
Panhandle and on the other side you have
Mobile Bay but the bottom of your oval
that's the Gulf Shore it's the Gulf of
Mexico so Baldwin County is one of two
counties in Alabama that borders the
Gulf of Mexico and the beaches are
called Orange Beach Gulf Shores and
they're literally if you look at a map
right next to Pensacola Beach or beaches
that you may know from Florida so it's a
continuation of the Florida coast except
it's in Alabama Obama and therefore more
affordable now in your story in the Wall
Street Journal you cite Census Data
showing the Baldwin County was the
fastest growing County in Alabama
between 2010 and 2020. what's the appeal
of that specific area of Alabama and how
do the living expenses compare to
Florida so the largest appeal of course
is affordability you set it houses are
cheaper there than they are either in
southwestern Florida or on the
southeastern shore of Florida where
people may have retired in the past the
cost of living is lower as well cost of
living of course depends on the average
salary in an area those things are
linked very closely and so in Baldwin
County the average salary is forty nine
thousand dollars and that compares to
fifty seven thousand dollars in Lee
County that's the county around Fort
Myers and 67 in Broward County now of
course if the average salary in a region
is lower that means your massages are
lower your dinners your grocery bills
and your gas ever everything is more
affordable I wanted to come back to one
thing you asked initially which is isn't
it great that in Florida there's no
state income tax well if you're an older
American who's no longer working you
don't have an income that's not so
relevant what is really relevant and
makes Baldwin County even more
attractive especially to older Americans
is that it has one of the lowest
property taxes in the country in the
nation all of Alabama and Baldwin County
as part of Alabama is no exception your
property taxes are so low that some of
the home buyers I interviewed for the
story when they first bought their homes
they couldn't believe how low it was
they thought oh wait is that yearly oh
no so that's another appeal so what does
this say about how economics have
changed for not only retirees but also
people planning for their retirement and
where they'll live it shows that people
are watching their dollars just a lot
more and as they're planning for
retirement they're also thinking about
where is a place where where I could buy
a property that I may be able to rent
out until I retire so while I'm still
winding down my job and in the last few
years of my career perhaps I already
lock in those low prices in this part of
Alabama now before they go up because
that will undoubtedly get discovered as
well I lock in that low price and rent
out this property have someone else pay
the mortgage until I'm ready to retire
there full time you mentioned the
economist with Florida Atlantic
University that you spoke with and that
person said that Baldwin County is
tailor-made for retirees is this A
playbook that other cities could follow
well what it has going for it what a lot
of other places may not is those sugary
beaches that has that small town feel it
has that affordability for now but
playbooks that other regions in the
country could follow is keeping their
property taxes low making themselves
attractive to seniors I think a big
Trend as well that we come across a lot
in our reporting is that second home
markets that are markets that may be
first attractive for snowbirds or people
who may want to rent their homes out
second home markets are increasingly in
driving distance from Big capitals where
in the old metropolitan areas where
perhaps in the past people would have
gotten that second home if they're
living in Philadelphia in Nantucket but
now they might get it in Cape May right
so for Baldwin County Alabama which is
in driving distance to Nashville to
Atlanta to some of the big Southern
capitals it's also by the way the first
County that you hit when you drive from
Texas it's the first really nice white
Beach that you can get those markets are
on the up much more perhaps in second
home markets there traditionally were in
Airplane distance people are attracted
to that white sand on the beach they are
and of course there's a Flora Bama the
world famous Honky Tonk and they are
very local attractions such as the deep
sea fishing rodeo things that only
happen in Alabama that's Wall Street
Journal contributor Cecile row wetter
and that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you